- Mir ist das doch vollkommen egal,
womit Sie sich
in Ihrer Freizeit beschäftigen. Aber
die Nachbarn haben sich beschwert.
- Wer hat sich beschwert?
Etwa Herr Murz?
Worüber denn?
- Na ja, es war den ganzen
Tag über sehr laut,
und da war ein großes Gedränge vor
der Eingangstür.
- Ein großes Gedränge …
- Ich gebe doch nur wieder, wovon mir
berichtet wurde.
- Ja, natürlich …
- Sie hätten mich einfach vorher
anrufen können.
Wofür gibt es heutzutage Handys?
- Wir haben den Hauseingang
extra frei gelassen
und zu den Ruhezeiten
war alles wieder abgebaut.
- Sie meinen …?
- Ich habe nichts falsch gemacht.
Ich meine …
Worüber reden wir hier eigentlich?
Haben Sie nichts Besseres zu tun?
Wir engagieren uns für Flüchtlinge
und Sie interessiert nur der Lärm?
- Überlassen Sie das doch
besser den Politikern.
- Ich finde,
dass Politiker viel zu wenig tun.
Also müssen wir uns eben selbst
mehr engagieren.
- Warum engagieren Sie sich nicht
direkt in der Politik?
- Vielleicht mach' ich das ja sogar.